drug research and development is more
challenging than ever requiring massive
amounts of data and complex analysis
join us as we talk to recursion
pharmaceuticals about how they're using
machine learning to speed up the drug
discovery process on this episode of
stack jack
Scot thanks so much for joining us today
can you tell us a little bit more about
what recursion Pharmaceuticals does yes
recursion is we're trying to bring new
drugs to market and you know in order to
do that we have to find new drugs
discover new drugs and and we're trying
to turn that problem into a machine
learning problem what what that means
how we do that is we are creating a
large data set consisting primarily of
cell microscopy images and so that means
we take a lot of pictures of a lot of
cells in a lot of different states so
healthy cells sick cells sick cells
combined with drugs healthy cells
combined with drugs and you try to learn
more information about how those images
change under different circumstances so
what does the architecture look like
that does the eventual machine learning
on these currently we're taking about 60
terabytes of images a week and so at the
beginning those that can take across
seven different microscopes about five
days at times to take that many images
and so we're constantly as as soon as
those images available we're uploading
them into GCS and sending off events
that those images are available for
processing and then we have a couple of
different kubernetes clusters rounding
on gke all our software is deployed in
there and we have a number of
applications that are reacting to these
events aggregating in different levels
and then scheduling processing on our in
our kind of jobs kubernetes cluster to
do different computation on the images
or the you know the results of previous
processing until we boil those down into
more refined features through this
feature extraction process and then
those features are used and analysis is
done runs through depending on the type
of experiment it runs through different
analyses where all these results all
these metrics quality metrics on the
images and a lot of different things are
stored in a combination of cloud sequel
and bigquery and then all that data is
used to make decisions and design our
next round of experiments and so that's
kind of
the process that we go through at
recursion on a weekly basis so it sounds
like you did a lot of data processing
directly in kubernetes with communities
jobs rather than using a traditional Big
Data solution like I do bro spark what
made you kind of choose to to write your
own in kubernetes
so I think there's a number of factors
so the two primary factors that pushed
us in that direction was that we have
all these images coming off the
microscopes constantly and and so we
have this kind of streaming flow of
images and in order to wait for the
right batches that that are the most
important it can take sometimes hours
but we want certain feedback on a lot of
those images much more quickly and and
so we wanted a streaming solution so we
get faster feedback on a lot of kind of
these quality metrics and stop problems
and save ourselves money from taking
pictures that aren't valuable the second
part of that was we had a number of
existing services that weren't written
in languages or in ways that integrate
nicely into some of those tools and so
some of those were you know cloud
functions or lambda jobs and other
things that we wanted to be able to not
have to rewrite all of that in order to
just orchestrate this pipeline awesome
well thanks so much for coming in until
I guess a little bit about how you built
this entire solution you know taking a
real big problem big data problem and
turning it into real insights yeah thank
you check out this quick guide to try
running kubernetes jobs of your own
thanks for watching and make sure to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content we'll see you next time
on stack jack
you